oh it's not even real you know how they
make the snow come down off to the flat
earth domes
all right well you did it oh no i was
kidding
price to pay friends and family so this
is him well you'll see
frankie b flat hello again all my
brothers and sisters
on our flat station
well he does have a very specific
cadence few friends
and um a lot of relatives
and ever since i found out the earth is
flat
and i talked to them about it
a few of them believe it
and they uh they're happy that i told
them
and uh they're all humoring you um
didn't they don't act the same way to me
anymore no could you pause
i'm all ready with this i'm so sick of
these [ __ ]
scumbags it's your narcissism
it's your you see frankie nobody cares
what your opinion is about what the
earth is people believe some dumb [ __ ]
um the problem frankie is with people
like you
people like others you you have to
accost everybody
you have to beat them over the [ __ ]
head
with your opinion about the earth being
flat
and then eventually people don't want to
be around you anymore right and family
just kind of humors you
but then you guys turn yourselves into
martyrs and you're like look at
look at everything i've done to try to
educate people from flat earth
my own family won't even talk to me at
christmas and it's like
well no you can the own benjamin you can
go into the room
you know what i mean like again at
christmas time i was saying last night
on night wave like
there's this we were saying it on rotc
too there's something you do at
christmas time you got kids around it's
family you're supposed to even just
pretend to like each other because it's
christmas time now later on at night
a little bit of booze flowing uh does
marsh start going a little heavy on the
j stuff
around the older relatives and the
nephews and stuff that are in their 20s
of course but i would never turn that
into a fight at christmas time where i'm
like
well if you're not going to believe that
the media and the banks
are are creating propaganda to destroy
your lives and flood immigrants in here
then i can't have christmas you see the
difference between the mental illness
and just having a spicy opinion
it's just times where you just go you
know like you go
guys these wizards are saying that the
moon is real
right somebody in the family generally a
senior male is supposed to go
hey hey come on just shut the [ __ ] up
dude snag it off right there's like the
kids opening up presents later
your wife's making cookies stop just
[ __ ] stop
so i this oh i hate people like this
because they could
continuously put themselves up on a
cross and go
it's so it's tough out there because for
some people won't listen to my flat
earth stuff and it's like
because you're on hour two of your
powerpoint presentation
the kids are trying to open gifts and
he's filming everybody
that's the other thing like i can't
imagine what his family goes through
because of what he does to strangers
that's kind of an indicator to me that
this man isn't sufferable the holidays
he doesn't shut the [ __ ] up well we
played the video of him with his family
right
there's a video yeah yeah hold on maybe
i i cuz i've watched i'm
so deep i'm so deep because he he's
again
uh uh again it's
whatever he's doing to these poor you
know the young black guy that was just
trying to work the produce section at
the [ __ ] store
and all these other people are just
trying to shop if you're that obnoxious
in public
i can't even imagine what you put your
family through
so this is um you haven't seen this one
they say it's swine and spinning the
earth
oh i thought it was just spinning
yeah but it's not we're not the third
[Music]
so they're all sitting there it looks
like it's someone's birthday or
something they're all about to have cake
there's no there's no
planets there's just lights in the sky
we never went to the moon yeah oh i knew
about i know and benjamin thanksgiving
you know when i went to new york for
christmas couple years ago
i i was trying to keep up with the
audience trying to you know you know how
it is when you take a whole week off you
usually really can't afford it and then
on top of it you want to give people
something so
i would go and i would do streams and i
would do stuff right
i would leave the room that my family
was in i would go downstairs they had a
basement with a pool table
where you could smoke don't go
downstairs you sit a little thing up hey
what's up guy i hope everybody's having
a good christmas
i'm here with the fit what you don't do
is just walk around and go hey did you
know that the earth is flat like
some people just want to be not bothered
you knew we never went to the moon how
did you know
um i followed this uh fbi agent
on youtube and he talks about
how
maybe while they say that old lady was
[ __ ] wolf in that cake
oh yeah she was going to town on that i
wanted that cake bed
oh soon they're not going anywhere you
know why it's going to be here
you can't break through the dome you
can't
like when you see how do you how do you
know though well it's like that cake
it's under a dome
how does he know but that i could break
that dome up
[Music]
and it starts to go this way you think
it's going around the earth yeah
all it's doing is all it's doing is
going
and then it's like everything else
whatever comes out that guy in the
background even walks like long island
trash oh yeah everybody's got that he's
got the
wattle yeah what's up you got that cake
in here
are we having some cake waddle waddle
that's a very long island italian like
they do this weird meat
right right like a duck they they walk
like they need penguins
exactly let's come down
so it goes up and it goes in the ocean
that's why they have it at
cape canaveral by the ocean yeah because
when it shoots up
it falls right into the ocean
she is just just playing along it's
great
it's all a big lie i kind of want to
like mr killjoy has the right idea
i'm gonna blow up the dome that wouldn't
that be yeah
i mean wouldn't that be the most
american thing to do blow up the dome
takes over 53 or 56 million dollars a
day
from us taxpayers every 24 hours
what's that i obama shut down the
program because my
brother-in-law was working for nasa
your brother-in-law works for nasa
did he ever tell you anything
[Music]
because okay let's say even it was fake
it's not obviously let's say everyone
that nasa's in every but the janitor at
nasa does
hey hey look i i just probably shouldn't
tell you this
it's just some guy speakers
no no hear me out check it out this is
all a scam dude did you know that
i know i take a garbage
a clean copy a keyboard on computers
i i don't know yet dude it's all scam
you should go tell your family
we're ripping the country off big time
but the earth being flat
yeah no he was just an engineer a
computer engineer
that's what it is i think a lot of
people that work for nasa they don't
even realize
that what they're doing uh you know
they're probably not informed they just
got to do their job you're right
frankie the guy the guy that worked
as a computer programmer for nasa
uh the higher calling that he wanted to
attain in life
is all [ __ ] frankie no you got you
got the inside track
frankie you know what i mean just the
obnoxiousness of that
is oh he says all pastors know it's in
the bible and pastors and preachers and
priests all know
and they don't tell anybody that's why
listen that's
why they [ __ ] little kids because they
know
uh that the dome you can't go you can't
go outside of the dome to [ __ ] the kids
you gotta do it
here um
one more thing with people saying remind
you of your thanksgivings mike
no i was just gonna say that it actually
this is you know what this feels like
first day back before the holidays were
you just there saying hi
and everybody's like do you want some
coffee you want some coffee mike no i'm
all right
get mike some coffee he wants coffee i
don't i'm i'm
all right on you get him some coffee and
some cake he wants coffee
cake he said he wants coffee okay i
never said any of this
no you'll fall off the edge you can't
there's a giant except we don't we don't
have a flat earther in my family we just
have a bunch of guys that sound like
frankie b-flat but they say things like
yeah you know this side this town used
to be really good remember when the
kohl's was there
before the puerto ricans moved in there
used to be
over here there used to be a roy rogers
uh but they turned it into a pep boys
when uh all the puerto ricans moved in
it's like he's just one of those guys we
have frankie b flats in my family
they're way more concerned about the
puerto ricans than they are
and we don't know what's on the other
side
yeah but i'll talk to you more about i
know yeah i'm sure she's [ __ ] waiting
with baited breath to talk about oh yeah
she can't wait
[Laughter]
in this family this would be the guy i
hang out with yeah just laughing at
everything
he's [ __ ]
don't say that you only see 33
everywhere
invited to storm the oh my god is this
woman wearing like
nursing scrubs yes she's a nurse
they're trying to do that no it's not
you know what there was there was
something going on with that
thousand couple thousand people gonna go
there
yeah you know joe biden right yeah
i don't know so now he's trying to
change so look here's what's happening
he's trying to change the topic from
flat earth watch how quickly he brings
it back to flat earth
i don't know personally no i know you
don't know a person but
you know about his his thing with
hugging the people and stuff
okay well hugging that girl touching
that girl oh
but what about him well that's what i'm
trying to get man
do you want him to be president no why
he's a real hero
frankie coming in with the not jokes did
he just do a [ __ ] borat
yeah not he is a great leader
nah no he is not a great leader
frankie i'm glad you never voted either
but keep it clean
[ __ ] boomer comedy two is the best
but it's like you know they're just
trying to
have fun you know and he should no but
you're not taking me seriously though i
gotta
everything has to be about what i wanted
to be a wrap about
in the chat goes i never voted either
not
we're bringing the not joke back it's
coming back
why is sam tripoli's dad there no cause
they say this guy
when he said he's going for president
but every time he sees the young girls
and stuff
he always touches them and stuff like in
the tv
listen to frankie all he has is flat
earth stuff
so he can't interject and have fun with
the rest of the family
no no but listen the dome is it's cold
we're gonna magnify god
[Music]
i'm definitely gonna vote for him for
president no he was mumbling
i was cracking up because they had the
guy asking a question about china
and he just went off where do we get
[ __ ] fresh
[ __ ] guy they asked him about [ __ ]
china and he's all like hey ching chong
bing bong and i'm like whoa
oh okay bing what are you doing enough
frankie all right
you know enough frankie there's so much
fun i didn't even mean to play it today
but
you brought him up